Tim Sullivan great columnist Louisville
courier-journal had an article it says
the cover up for Triple Crown winner
justify looks shameful no matter how its
framed here the Kentucky Horse Racing
Commission says that they had no
knowledge of the Triple Crown winner the
drug usage until yesterday and Tim kind
enough to join us on short notice what
do you make of this story here Tim what
do you expect to happen well I think
what we're seeing now is that the
Kentucky Derby has become the most
litigious two minutes in sports and this
is a fascinating case on a lot of levels
but the thing that is most interesting
to me is the behavior of the California
horse racing board and it's I don't know
what else to call it other than the
cover-up of a positive drug test of the
Santa Anita Derby winner who went on to
win the Triple Crown whether the the
drug in question had any significant
impact in justify his performance is
something I'm not qualified to comment
on but that the CHR be ignored its own
precedent and conceal disinformation
seem to drag its feet between learning
of the first positive drug test and
notifying Bob Baffert is very curious
and raises questions about whether there
was an intent to slow-walk this so that
he would remain eligible for the Derby
since the the second confirming test
didn't come back till three days after
the Derby so they have a lot of
explaining to do and
I haven't heard an explanation yet that
was very persuasive is this about money
mount ratings about making sure you had
the best horse in the race
triple crown like all of the above well
I mean I think there's all kinds of
motors I mean this is a sport that where
the value of these thoroughbreds after
they run can be tremendous I think
justifies breeding right sold for
something on the order of seventy five
million dollars and he's getting I think
because as advertised radius I'm one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
shot so there is huge money at stake
here and when you you have a financial
interest in a derby horse
be it as a an owner a trainer or someone
in the industry who sees an opportunity
to to raise the the level for everyone
you know I think you're inherently
conflicted our members of the CHR B who
have horses with Bob Baffert I don't
know how that can be allowed and you
know but it is and I think there's going
to have to be some significant reforms
that come out of this whether this
affects you know justifies standing as a
Triple Crown winner you know I think
it's unlikely he would be stripped of
any of those those races but you know
that the question remains you know if he
was tested positive after the the said I
needed Derby why did it take so long for
for that word to to get to Baffert why
did it take so long for the second
positive test to come back and why was
that concealed for more than a year Tim
thanks for joining us on short notice we
appreciate your time my pleasure that's
Tim Sullivan columnist Louisville
courier-journal for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]